♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE CONSTITUTION
PROHIBITS THE GOVERNMENT FROM
CENSORING NOT MUCH OF THE
SPEECH, FACEBOOK IS IMPOSING ITS
OWN BRAND OF POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS ON ITS OWN PLATFORM.
FACEBOOK BANDS ALEX JONES, MILO
AND EVEN LOUIS FARRAKHAN AND NOW
THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT IS GOING
TO STEP FURTHER BY CENSORING
CONSERVATIVE COMMENTATOR.
SHE WAS OPPOSING FACEBOOK
CENSORSHIP.
SHE JOINS ME KNOW.
HER FIRST TELEVISION COMMENTS
ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
THE POST THAT WAS TAKEN DOWN, I
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT WILL BE
UNTIL I AM NEXT.
I LOVE IT.
KIND OF TAUNTED THEM AND YOU
DEMONSTRATED WHAT WAS GOING ON
BUT ARE YOU NOW ON THE VERGE OF
BEING JUST A BAND ON FACEBOOK?
>> I THINK A LOT OF US ARE AND I
THINK THERE IS A COMMONALITY
AMONG MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING TARGETED ON FACEBOOK AND
ON TWITTER COME ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
I HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT MY OWN
WEBSITE.
IT'S HOSTED BY WORDPRESS WHICH
IS NOW GOING AFTER PEOPLE BASED
ON THEIR IDEOLOGICAL VIEWPOINTS.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS NEXT X
ESSENTIAL BATTLE AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT.
I'VE MADE A LIVING OVER THE LAST
25 YEARS, AND LOTS OF IT ONLINE
AND HAVE NEVER HAD TO WORRY
ABOUT THIS KIND OF DEEP
PLATFORMING.
I'M SAYING THIS BECAUSE WE NEED
A VIBRANT MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS.
WE NEED AN INFORMED CITIZEN RATE
FOR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLICS TO
FUNCTION AND WHEN FACEBOOK AND
SILICON VALLEY OVERLOADS HAVE
THEIR THUMB ON FREE SPEECH AND
THAT IS A CONCERN FOR ALL OF US.
THERE IS A LOT TO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED FORMED, FOLKS
MIGHT
BE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH BUT ALL I
DID THAT CAUSED FACEBOOK TO
CENSOR ME WAS SIMPLY STAND UP
FOR A COUPLE OF MY FRIENDS.
NOW EVEN I USING MY FACEBOOK
PLATFORM THAT HAS 2.1 MILLION
FOLLOWERS COULD NOT EVEN MENTION
THEIR NAMES WITHOUT BEING
ACCUSED OF VIOLATING THE
COMMUNITY STANDARDS OF FACEBOOK.
THERE'S A LOT MORE GOING ON AND
I BELIEVE IT HAS TO DO WITH A
2020 ELECTION AND MAKING SURE
THAT SOMEHOW THOSE OF US WHO
SUPPORT THE AGENDA OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP ARE BEING
THROTTLED AND MANAGED AND
MARGINALIZED.
I AM SENDING UP AN ALARM.
I WILL CONTINUE TO USE MY
PLATFORM.
>> Laura: I LOVE THE DEFIANCE.
HE WAS ON TV THIS WEEKEND AND HE
BASICALLY ISSUED A WARNING.
>> THE WAY THE RULES OF THE
INTERNET HAVE DRAWN TODAY IN MY
VIEW HAVE NOT BEEN DRAWN ARE
QUITE DIFFERENT TO THE WAY THEY
ARE DRAWN AND TEN YEARS' TIME
BUT I THINK BIG TECH COMPANIES
HAVE A CHOICE.
EITHER THEY PLAY BALL AND THEY
TRY TO PLAY A RESPONSIBLE ROLE
IN THAT DEBATE BEFORE THEY TRY
TO DOCKET ALTOGETHER.
>> Laura: LUCKY EUROPE HAS
GOTTEN ALL OVER FACEBOOK,
TOUGHER THAN THE UNITED STATES
WITH PRIVACY ISSUES BUT HE SAID
WE WILL HAVE NO CHOICE.
>> WHAT TWO PEOPLE DO?
PEOPLE ASKED ME AFTER MY SPEECH
AND OVER THE PAST YEAR AND NOW
THAT WE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE
DISAPPEAR AND BE ON PERCENT ON
THE ONE THING PEOPLE CAN DO IS
FIGHT BACK WITH THEIR
POCKETBOOKS AND THE VOICES THEY
DO HAVE.
SUPPORT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DISAPPEARED.
THERE'S WEBSITE CALLED FIGHT THE
SENSORS THAT IS HELPING PEOPLE
WHOSE NAMES I CAN'T SAY ON
FACEBOOK, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF
I CAN TEST THE FACEBOOK LIVE
INSTRUMENT FUNCTION WHICH IS
ALSO BEING THROTTLED.
APPARENTLY IF YOU GO AGAINST
THEIR STANDARDS THEY WILL TAKE
THAT AWAY.